so no so i wanted to do this and i don't
remember how i got a meeting with t.i
but like he we were like trying to get
oh we were trying to get a rapper to
like co-sign us and and and uh get
behind us and so we had this meeting
with ti
and um in l.a in la it was at the some
hotel and and we were like so what did
we do and uh you know how do we get this
going and he was like look i'm gonna be
honest with you he was like this is not
hot
[Laughter]
you want some water i gotta go oh you
got water okay you got water you got
water i got water what you got there is
that coffee and bourbon nah man just
straight bourbon
daddy coffee
[ __ ] you got coffee here and
bourbon
what are you 80 this is coffee that's
eight shots of espresso wait is that a
drink
it's coffee drink dog bad shots of
espresso what that is what you're
holding no what about this this is uh oh
it's not apple juice
hold on it's
i mean
what bro i know it comes out at tell
them it's not guys it's not 9 00 pm just
so you know it's 9 p.m on a thursday
oh really
really what happened in the news
yesterday then dude
yesterday yeah yeah wednesday it's crazy
it is crazy
dude it's crazy there's a there's new uh
covet variant there's no co-appearance
and then also uh california opened back
up wide open oh yeah wide open and then
also neil young
he's not on spotify anymore oh wow what
are you doing old news like what are you
doing what is this what is that this is
intervention you don't recognize
do i admire those people on the
intervention man everyone wants to clown
them those meth heads are shredded and
it's always their warlock family like
you gotta get out of the house this is
rock bottom like he looks better than
most y'all [ __ ] yeah because everyone
yeah people get it's always like they're
they're always trying to drag in the
skinniest person and like you have a
problem and everyone else is just like
you're like you'll be eat burgers all
day long but i will tell you though but
i will tell you though that that show i
can't [ __ ] watch it too not anymore
too depressing heartbreaking the worst
when they have kids oh dude
i'll cause i record all of them
you know what you know it's the same one
hoarders is the same way oh dude because
at the end of hoarders they they always
go like they and they show like a little
like what they're doing it's like and
she never got the house back and she's
not living in a homeless shelter yeah
just like that's how you're going to end
it i know
hoarders is like shark week it's all the
same [ __ ] can i get some new can i get
some sort of spin on it dude you know
what how sharp we'd go on like i can
only see so many great whites jump out
of the wall yeah like every year it's
the same yeah on hoarders it's like you
just because you're just it's just a
matter you keep saying the same thing
when you watch it you go
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i don't i don't see how those shows do
like like just non-stop seasons like my
600 pound life yeah no
all set uh yeah i saw two episodes
you've seen you know i'm asked can i ask
a question no way hold on okay go ahead
i'm ready you ready for this question
because i still want to talk about
holders behind yeah oh no go to orders
okay so
i have a question about 600 pounds okay
so i watched hoarders i watched orders a
few times you know i have ocd like i
know what so i get it right when i was
[ __ ] 16 i collected a whole bunch of
[ __ ] and i thought i actually had the
wherewithal to think well this is gonna
be a real problem so i threw away all my
[ __ ]
i threw away all my [ __ ] and i and i was
like and it [ __ ] it was really hard
but i'm so glad i did that because i
would still be collecting like
mcdonald's fry containers and [ __ ] right
that's what you were collecting yeah
that's the ocd
real
ocd but hers is like if it's out of
place yeah yeah yeah yeah everything has
been yeah but that's here's the
difference between that
hd so no here's the difference between
that and real ocd she's like oh i can't
wait to organize to make it nice me i'm
dreading going home because i got to fix
everything that's the difference right
okay so it's like ooh but i like it
clean but no no no no i don't even want
to go home because i have to try to move
the hangers around and [ __ ] like that's
what oh you've got that touch
i mean i'm not that's not my thing but
yes it's like that oh wow yeah but i
don't do that but yeah you're free yeah
i'm a freak dude he's like this he got a
oh just doesn't go here yeah yeah yeah
really
but here's but but so with the hoarders
i watched it so i was like man i really
feel for these [ __ ] because i
kind of get it but then i saw the
episode where the guy was like the house
was a mess and and they were like so
this is all you have and he was like
well come out back
dude there was an additional dwelling
unit and he was collecting his own [ __ ]
oh dude he had buckets of his own [ __ ]
he doesn't even want to give that up
dude
oh my god and i couldn't watch it
anymore of course but you can relate to
it a little bit but he had an additional
dwelling unit and i get it and you know
what i like and i get it you know what i
love about hoarders every person on
hoarders is very attractive every single
one of the soldiers i don't know
dude they're all warlocks maybe you're
in
one hot person yeah yeah when you're hot
you don't have time to collect stuff
he's not a bad looking dude i got good
looking i'm throwing my fries i got good
looking yeah it was like like you were
like yeah you look in the mirror like
he passed by the mirror i was like wait
a minute i'm really coming into my own
just in the trash i don't have ocd
there's certain things like yesterday we
had christa stefano on fire in the kid
and he came in with uh adidas socks with
van shoes yeah and they were like loud
adidas with van shoes that would drive
me nuts i i was so focused on it i
missed a bit he was doing oh wow wait
what did you say he's always doing a bit
so yeah
that's that's bad to do i don't like
mixing the the stuff i've done it and
then i've since grown to be like i don't
think i should be doing that it'll ruin
my day like if i re like if i do it on
accident and i'll be sitting here and
yeah i'm in jeans like yeah i used to
not care about it but you know life
changes and other things become
important and now it's all like you're
all adidas what were you gonna say about
yeah you know you you know these people
that they can't what go ahead make your
fat joke
i know you stopped it yeah
it was in your head it's too much it's
too much it's too much i was going to
say but you tried out for it but the
thing is
no i i don't i don't like those [ __ ]
jokes i i think you did and i did it too
later you do you like what are you doing
about six round life
you know they can't get out of bed
right and some can but yeah but the ones
that can't get out of bed
i just go shouldn't the first day you
can't get out of bed be the first day of
the diet
shouldn't that be the first day of the
day because they're like [ __ ] it no and
then their skin turns into basically
dinosaurs but here's the thing like
around their thighs you can't get out
like what was that like that first day
must have been like
yeah
okay what
hold up here yeah wait what the heck
whoever's bringing them food need to get
they asked the enablers yeah but why
does their skin turn into like straight
like like t-rex skin around like their
thighs and their oh my god
it's not but
that's still smashed that one that was
on the couch
have you seen thousand pound sisters no
no
you haven't seen that and the one has
for whatever you know some people put
fat on the back of their neck tell me
hers goes on the floor
oh come on man oh man dude it's insane
at least you can get massages without
using that [ __ ] thing you know what i
mean it keeps you breathing
um i never seen you laugh that hard
because you know why because i get
massages all the time i hate where my
face is
dude it's like
your face was like
i know i would love a little fourth
i saw this thing on instagram just like
this woman in hollywood she was like she
wrote this op-ed piece about like
calling for show runners and
entertainment people stopped making fat
jokes i saw it i saw it she goes trust
me they're not funny
[Music]
look at how hard you just laugh yeah
it's like don't say it's not funny
because it's funny fat jokes are funny
just saying don't be honest
we're not being mean i know but it's
like we're not jealous with her
on the massage
what we're saying is at any point you
can change your life just look at our
boy george he lost 200.
270 pounds you see how he's a year and a
half really yeah yeah we flew him out
here and he he's 200 he's like i think
that's all for me now yeah he's down
hold on
but when you get to this kind of a thing
it's not i know i get it like the joke's
like well how come the first day i can't
i can't get up out of the bed that's
when the diet starts but it's a mental
thing these guys are really fun they're
sick and they're sad and like they're
depressed and it's [ __ ] hard when
you're there dude like it's hard to
[ __ ] do something when you don't want
to but also when you roll up to
mcdonald's or carl's jr in their order
i'm like
yeah yeah yeah yeah bro they go
so hard in the pain but what he's saying
is like so true because even for myself
like i've been a big guy in my later
adult life like for a long time so
recently because of covet and all this
and seeing the numbers i was like i'm
trying to work like this morning i
worked out oh yeah like i had to get up
yeah i got up at eight o'clock and then
i got i have i bought a rowing machine
yeah yeah those are good yeah yeah so i
so i said i got to do this every day wow
so every day i'm at home i get i do
no matter how i feel disciplined and so
then if you were to get coven he's like
i started today because you're healthy
no it's also because like you deserved
it my mom has dementia yeah yeah i know
my mom has dementia and i was like so
i'm thinking about like i'm about to be
50 this year and i was like i need to
get my [ __ ] together to get married like
she want to have kids
600 pound life dad yeah those kids i
feel so bad for
so here we are good dude that's cool
yeah yeah
i'm trying oh damn
there's you would be you're waiting
honestly no you look you look better
than than you do there
no i'm saying he's way better yeah
but it's all the other stuff too it's
like body fat and all this kind of stuff
i got my cholesterol down i got my blood
sugar down i got you know my
inflammation down i'm working on all
that stuff dude that's real 50. yeah
dude
yeah
50. brendan will never see that and
it's no yeah yeah i'm i'm like a uh i'm
a great dane what are you like 39 now 38
38 yeah that's you're almost yeah yeah
12 years
honestly i'm thinking like 61 yeah two
gets dicey for you yeah yeah yeah
there's another like plague or something
yeah that cte is gonna finally break
through oh god dude but it won't be the
ct that kills you
well ct is just ruined it's gonna be
this yeah oh gotcha your career yeah
yeah oh wow oh this got dark maybe you
can take yourself out before a disease
does oh my gosh nice but this is really
dark but it has to be on the podcast
on my super cast patreon fans only yeah
you mentioned uh and then i'll be
selling merch afterwards like he made
i'm just not doing well man i spent
another day yeah it's only one but he'll
be doing that on his podcast
he's on his podcast like guys i'm just
not feeling myself right now i'm working
too much
yeah [ __ ] while he's interviewing a
leaf blower
[Laughter]
and for no reason kid rock is just
walking in the background in a row
would they go brandon shirt on
he sends in the video to the your eulogy
to the funeral so i can make again man i
just need some rest man i'm doing i have
seven shows tonight at the hollywood
you know there's two parts to this
business brother what's that well
there's wedding jewelry if you're
considering getting married or
taking on another wife sure and then
there's everyday fine jewelry if you
want to get somebody a nice
you know ex you know excalibur do uh get
a nice uh earrings or bracelets but bro
also valentine's day is coming up dude
and you need something that's really
fire you need something that says i love
you that's where blue now comes in man
celebrate your love with jewelry from
bluenow.com shop now and take advantage
of the valentine's day sale 50 off on
select jewelry up to fit up to 50 off
and blue nile it's insured so if they
mail into somebody you know there's a
smash and grab you still get you know
you're good it ships free arrives in
discreet packages they'll mail it maybe
it'll mail it in a guitar case or
something nobody's gonna know what's
going on smuggle it in man find your
forever piece go to bluenow.com today we
talking 50 off select jewelry for
valentine's day bluenow.com that's right
and maybe you can't get somebody
something you know all the time but you
get them that nice piece that jewelry it
lets them keep it on their neck keep it
on their wrist you know it's a reminder
maybe we got a man out there dude get
him a diamond studded narrowing you know
get him yeah dude get him a little
tennis bracelet for his weiner buddy
love love baby bluenile.com look man
i'll tell you this the nfl playoffs who
even thought these teams would be in it
i mean i've expected the chiefs but the
bangles the niners who day bro i'm
running with joe burrow man that's where
i'm at right now
and the niners i would like to see maybe
oh no no no no we need cincinnati and
the rams to get it done but listen don't
listen to us there's four teams that are
left in the nfl playoffs and you're
gonna bet on it do it with draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner the nfl and they got a deal for
you big dog they got a deal for you bee
sting let me tell you this
new customer
they're gonna give you 56 to one odds on
any team that's in that final four bet
just five dollars
and get 280
in free bets if your team wins yep if
you're not a new customer you can
experience the comp friendship
championships with the same game parlays
all you do you can combine multiple bets
from the same game for a bigger payout
the more legs you add the more bank you
win son draftkings is safe secure
reliable best of all you can deposit
withdrawal whenever you want yup
download the draftking sportsbook app
n-o-w baby now use promo code k-a-t-s
and get 56 to one odds on any nfl team
bet just five dollars and win 280 in
free bets if your team wins that's promo
code k-a-t-s for 56-1 odds at draftking
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl must be 21 or older
new jersey indiana and pennsylvania only
new customers only minimum five dollar
positive one dollar wager required one
per customer restrictions apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem call 100 gambler
uh you mentioned neil young earlier this
guy had a debate club about joe and neil
okay what's up king of this thing it's
your boy edwin i got a mystery stolen
club for you
i was reading my news yes i got my
christmas tree up oh
is this a zoom
neil young going to spotify saying it's
either me or joe rogan oh joe rogan out
here posting these anti-vaxx [ __ ]
well who do you guys got i got joe
neil young
maybe we got two three years left of him
hope kobe get him but let me know what
you guys think dude peace peace gang
gang
so so neil came neil young came out he
here's the thing with context so neil
young has always had an issue with
spotify he didn't want his entire
catalog on spotify because he thinks
their sound quality is bad so apparently
they came to agreement with like all
right we'll take all your catalogs we'll
enhance the audio yeah he's like all
right cool and then now you know rogan
he's saying spreading misinformation
where to each its own all right if you
believe that he's like it's either me or
joe rogan spotify is like
excuse me yeah oh we're we're good like
the only way and i think
to defend neil young a little bit here
he did he had polio he got he beat polio
he beat uh he has type one diabetes and
he had i think uh aneurysm or heart
attack so he has underlying health
conditions totally get it yeah but he's
alive he's a he's 76 or 78 do you get
coveted he i don't think he has if he
doesn't get screwed but the thing is is
you're not going to shake the tree of
spotify threatening them with if you're
it would take like i'm being dead
serious it would take like
so their top three streamers i think is
dozia cat uh drake and kanye if the
three of them came out like it's either
us
all right joe we gotta figure something
out right neil young yeah name a song
chris uh then we're too young i don't
know
i don't know i don't know
if i heard it i'd be like oh that's neil
young
i listened before i came here you'll
know some but you're not gonna be like
oh man i can't live without neil young
yeah yeah definitely take rogue oh yeah
well this is more like him bringing it
up just to start the conversation i
think it's more i think that he really
is doing that that's what it really is i
don't think he cares about you know i
think he's kind of set you know what i'm
saying like financially i don't think oh
yeah spotify giving him money to for his
album
how much money does neil young have and
also [ __ ] three three years left
yeah it's like dude this is the fight
you want to do in the last you're in
your fifth round dude it's not going to
matter nobody also take your christmas
tree down but anyway yeah for sure you
know what i mean but the thing is um
like neil young like about the the
quality of spotify i mean to me this has
been a thing that's been going on
forever i mean once they went to mp3s
mp3s are a low-grade quality sound and
that's what spotify uses yeah but this
is this young generation
they don't even understand like on cds
those are wave files that are like 40
gig files you know that's why the sound
quality is so much better but because it
went to downloading and all this stuff
no one cares sound quality the sound
quality's been degraded for now for like
10 years i don't know that people don't
even they don't they just young people
just like oh it sounds good to me so the
record companies and everybody are like
okay just put that down wait why do you
know all this stuff it's almost 70. but
that's i forget that [ __ ] dude yeah
that's a real thing
tattoo
no i'm just saying mp3s are a low grade
quality man and and that's so that's all
if that's the standard it's like but you
know even on your spot
you can download a higher quality you
could do that on youtube it takes longer
though right yeah but it is what it is
so i get it so i get him but he's old
too so he remembers like you know
putting a record yeah yeah
but from his i try to look at other
people's perspective from his
perspective
several underlying health conditions who
knows what happened within his family so
he's probably like yeah super pro cove
and that's fine dude do your thing but
do you really think it's you're going to
make the difference
it's an unfair characterization to say
that joe rogan is spreading
uh you know that information that they
think just be like if joe rogan has
somebody on that has a different opinion
then they blame joe rogan when he's just
when he's just there he has everybody on
the show but he's always the guy from
cnn on his show to give her to give him
a chance yeah so he has everybody on the
show him apart but anyways but i think
i think it is joe's having the
conversation that nobody else is happy
like he's having a doctor who hey man i
was part of creating these vaccinations
this is what i think then i'll have the
doctor on cnn on in a long form three
hours yeah name another platform i can't
name another platform any of these
people with your doctor
whoever you are comic whoever that you
get three hours to [ __ ] speak your
truth if that's what you believe so
that's the reason joe's so much bigger
than cnn and fox news because fox news
cnn they have an agenda joe doesn't have
an agenda you could come on and [ __ ]
preach about moderna or whatever it is
or uh conspiracy theories all right he's
into it he doesn't care there's no
agenda he's not booking guests based off
agenda
yeah i mean they didn't like they didn't
allow him to have alex jones on right no
he did
spotify is owned by a savage of a man
and he's swedish he doesn't partake in
any of this woke and all this [ __ ] a
little bit all he doesn't he does
he does how in what form my episodes
aren't on there
that's not good yeah i wrote an episode
on there ooh it just got dark no i mean
but but remember i don't think that's
the president that's yeah spotify new
york which they took several but they
took more than yours off yeah oh yeah
yeah
brendan that's what i'm saying they took
gavin what's that whatever else kevin
mcguinness
yeah they took him off i mean look you
know he took some alec jones off but i
but again i don't i think the president
took joey diaz off
no they did dude yes they did yes they
did
so
you know i and and like you said maybe
it's not the president
but but but you know we're starting now
you know what i don't know yeah if
you're stupid i've heard from what i've
heard and i have friends who work for
spotify for what i heard it's not his
doing he's like yeah like so but they
didn't do it but back to neil young if
neil young isn't on spotify you know
what their stock does nothing if joe
rogan left spotify their stock went up
two billion dollars yeah yeah yeah
so what do you so
that that swedish dude's a businessman
you know yeah i get that uh
yeah i get it i just you know it's like
i i don't think i i didn't know that
about your episodes yeah yeah but no but
here's the deal though again you know
and here's the other thing like you know
that's not joe
dude right chris came out the other day
that's all i'm saying him i know i'm not
trying to be pushed over to the right
dragon i'm a centrist tonight
oh no
i know
oh
yeah wait are you they took your
opponent
around there like venom right now
i am right chris
you are
always flying in a circle with two right
wings
like nascar
put alex jones back on spotify
right wing chris is insane dude what do
you think of neil young right chris
i will eat
young's children
it is about the corporations and [ __ ]
like that because remember donald
sterling the ex-owner of the clippers
that guy been racist for 40 years nobody
did anything nobody said anything once
pepsi and coke and all those companies
were like yeah we're pulling out of the
staples center the nba was like business
he got to go but
everyone knew that this guy was [ __ ]
racist yeah they were like nba was like
he's gotta go look at these
[ __ ] everyone knew but did he
say the n word because remember his girl
i don't know
you're gonna believe that [ __ ] idiot
have you seen it
that's what i'm saying yeah so that
listen uh
but she recorded it but like when you
hear the when you hear them playing he's
all do you have to [ __ ] all the black
guys like
do they have to be seven foot tall
you know what say like you never dropped
the n-word he was just like do you have
to [ __ ] it was a question he was
posing a question yeah and they're like
get him out of here dude i don't know it
was a [ __ ] accumulation of all the
officials i didn't hear the recordings
but dude bro people [ __ ] people do
this [ __ ] everyone's acting holier than
now you [ __ ] [ __ ] off dude you know i
agree and pepsi like they give a [ __ ] yo
bro you think the guy is at the top of
pepsi you think he's not racist dude
[ __ ] who is the owner who gives a
[ __ ]
he's so rare i have to do you know that
guy at the end what does he want to say
how old is he oh is he over what oh then
he's right he's over 50 there's probably
over 50 next year
if he was white next year dude he'd be
so racist that's 50. bro
i say this all the time look at this guy
look at this guy who do you want he
dropped something who do you vote for
yeah
wait what's what's up with that name is
he [ __ ]
ramon you know what you know what i
don't understand this like sell it to
[ __ ] armenian people also search for
when you search for that guy they're all
because why would you search for these
people because
in indra play probably owns [ __ ]
sprite yeah laxman probably owns
coca-cola aj owns some other [ __ ] who's
caleb i just literally destroyed those
names uh former ceo former ceo
hey destroy whatever i mean
i want to see brendan in a spelling bee
that would be
yeah can you use those words in a
sentence please bro i'll never forget i
had an audition for the ufc tonight on
fox when they were just starting and
just my [ __ ] luck it was all
the coal card was brazilian fighters
like brennan what do you think about
nuzzle
does he have a nickname yeah can you use
his name in a sentence give him
nicknames dude
just and that was it for your tv crew
they're like
we're good we're good yeah you're not
great at the the english language
this guy's got a debate club
what up king of the state it's your boy
that's the same guys last time i got a
debate club
you got that
my life is a documentary hitter by
chance smith that is a hitter or that
island boy dish oh chain oh dude it's
the street [ __ ] versus nothing i mean
i'm close boy is not a thing they're
just [ __ ] around chuck smith is real
that's from the heart you know can you
play the the chat one chet hanks i i'm a
huge fan of chet hanks oh wait
wait hold on no they're talking about
the island boys but what's the other guy
chris smith remember thanks smith back
in the day when chris was a rapper
oh oh you thought it was just me
that's okay such a fan that's a good
debate club too chat chatter change code
i love chat yeah
life
this is very good i had a meeting with
t.i about this
yeah
really all right i really did it
holy [ __ ] i couldn't wait to get out of
that meeting
bro it was the worst [ __ ] meeting it
was unbelievable
and if baltimore is primp then this
versus the wire shank smith
that's good
[ __ ]
i mean this was how long ago this
destroys island boys yeah what is that
2020 it was an earlier one this is like
a 2015 was the this is what it released
this was a you re-uploaded in 2015. i
know yeah so tell me this is older how
the [ __ ] did you get a meeting with ti
based out there
so
[Laughter]
so i wanted to do like a [ __ ] follow
shank smith around his life
where like he was like uh coming
moving out of prim and coming to la to
follow his dreams as like a 30 [ __ ]
five-year-old and what's prim
is a place in um hunger games no prison
near las vegas no prim is a place on the
way to las vegas where he's from okay
and nobody is from there it's just a
place where you stay
it's live so it's a character you
created right so then t.i what sees this
video wait do you have to get off at yyz
no yeah
so so no so i wanted to do this and i
don't remember how i got a meeting with
t.i but like he we were like trying to
get oh we were trying to get a rapper to
like co-sign us and and and uh get
behind us and so we had this meeting
with t.i
and um in l.a in l.a it was at the some
hotel t.i walked in with uh
three he had he goes like this uh what's
up and he put he put his he had three
phones and he put them down on the table
and during the meeting he would get a
text and he would be like checking which
phone it was
figured out i'm not lying i'm not i'm
not even joking yeah it wasn't before it
wasn't two it was three phones it's too
much but it's just silly to be like i
know like have different notifications
there were three iphones and um
and and we were like so what did we do
and uh you know how do we get this going
and he was like look i'm gonna be honest
with you he was like this is not hot
[Laughter]
he was like he was like this is not hot
and i was like yeah it is dude i was
like this is good and he was like no it
is not and i was like bro
it's [ __ ] and he was like if you're
trying to do like the curb your
enthusiasm larry david [ __ ] he he
literally goes like this i ain't with
that
and i'm like why did you hear that yeah
i didn't understand why he was there
yeah you know i'm not trying to get side
to [ __ ] no no no i don't know i i
don't think he understands i'm going to
be very clear about this i don't think
he understands humor yes i don't think
he understands he's trying to stand up
now though
no
well it will be horrible oh it's going
to be terrible yeah he got music
i'm going to be in the artist no no no
no i'm going to be in the audience he's
going to be doing something
like
i don't get he's getting booed because
he's talking about how women cheat too
can you be in a committed relationship
well
a friend from the opposite six
yes like
ladies yesterday way better than us so
don't get into the game okay because of
the [ __ ]
women be shopping too
this is a women bee shop here's the
thing though i'm sure someone this is
look look i already agree with you
somebody somebody went to him
no no somebody went to him and said his
people said you know you can make a lot
of money
no he has so much money i bet he was so
bored i know like and i bet his girl
whatever tiny i was like you funny he's
like you think she's like yeah there's
so many people it's called you just
start doing stand up and they'll just be
killing it at the at clubs and stuff
like that and making so much money
now that it only lasts you can get away
with that for a year you go on a run for
a year okay
there's no longevity i know but then he
don't need the longevity like you said
he already this is just like hey i
didn't remember when i did that for a
year but also rap you know like will
smith
he could start if will smith want to
like he could do a stadium tour yeah as
a comic right now right charlie sheen
did and then once
he got booed he got booted so he made it
through three cities and by the fourth
one the word was out on twitter how
terrible he is and then his ticket sales
but my whole thing is like all these
jeff ross and russell peters helped him
out all these [ __ ] think that
stand up that was like all right well
last last last
i'll just do stand-up last day like you
know i didn't do all the other [ __ ] fine
you can do stand-up now but also build a
house and live in that yeah because
you're not a [ __ ] architect or a or
you know you're not that either yeah bro
yeah you're not that easy the least
respected art form is standing yeah and
the end truly we're fighting the hardest
yeah like [ __ ] off by far [ __ ] off the
hardest you need immediate laughs even a
painting people could draw a [ __ ]
nice renaissance [ __ ] people could
[ __ ] paint [ __ ] it's beautiful as
[ __ ] and someone came like ah 900 people
could look at that at the same time i'd
be like i don't really like it who gives
this [ __ ] the guy already painted it but
when you're up there bombing that's the
hardest [ __ ] dude especially when you
got to follow other monsters i know i
don't even know it's not that like it's
not at home they don't even matter how
famous you are either i don't know how
many times it doesn't matter
they give they'll give that person like
a minute like i've seen somebody like
super famous like the crowd go you know
they go and guess who's here you know
that's why i always like i love chris
rock always does this when he like he's
doing like a like he's just whatever he
comes in and goes hey lower your
expectations
mean i'm working [ __ ] out you know and
then like you see him in two weeks and
it's fire yeah right yeah i mean like
it's just if you're not if you don't
have that work ethic
people don't care they give you a minute
man i'll give you a minute no matter how
oh then they come out of halloween i'll
never forget we're at the laugh factory
and the very famous guy was going on
stage she's trying to do stamps still
does it not doing well
and i remember i was like man they seem
excited for him and brian looks at me
goes
he'll have 45 seconds of that after that
if he's not funny i'm telling you dude
this can get [ __ ] dark for me i went
no they love this guy they know him from
blah blah he goes 45 seconds it's la
they're gonna give you 45 seconds maybe
another state should get two minutes and
mike
michael richards has never done comedy
it was me
um do you still have ti's info you got
it i don't think so you gotta text him
that youtube video be like that's not
hot yeah but which phone i have yeah i
don't know what phone i have no but you
know what um
uh i i got a whole new i have a whole
nother album from cheney smith no [ __ ]
they haven't really oh it's not out it's
not
dude you and chet hank should do like
dude i have seven songs oh my god bro
you know what oh dude oh you know what
happened
to clown chris deleon you know what
would happen if we put you know little
brows might get a little brown yeah i
put little brows i don't think chet
hanks and you yeah together yeah do you
hate money no i i love money and
honestly all right well well i'm [ __ ]
dude i have seven songs i'm open to do
collabs bro tell me tell me if you think
this is
business let us play this that's how a
drug dealer like you know what i mean
it's not just you taste it
do you hate money
yeah he should be one of those like
self-help guys that would be his thing
let me just tell you right now this new
[ __ ] that chang smith did
it's just [ __ ] fire dude oh it's fire
yeah it is even ti be like all right all
right i'm i'm with it and it's it'll
come out i just have the right do what i
was sitting on
let's do a video like
myself
my real name is austin been working so
hard been recording these songs every
night and i'm [ __ ] exhausted ain't
been sleeping i'm still fighting demons
and nothing is helping to clear up my
conscience when i think about not living
up to my full potential why just start
to get nauseous need a psychiatrist wait
let me write this [ __ ] hold on just let
it ride don't try to fight this [ __ ] hit
record turn to annihilus don't know to
feel like podiatrist you know it's gang
like a tribalist hold on away
don't get ahead of myself
[ __ ] that tell the engineer to punch me
in and just keep punching me it's a lot
of punch on their license you've been
had to drive with no license the hardest
the fire boy arson is doubling triple
entendres i'm in my own world with the
juice like it's john but mentality mom
but a boy been a problem and i'm so
focused you can read it in my persona
see it in my persona stepping in
designing depth before designer if you
forgot then let me remind you i am no
amateur snapped like a camera whenever i
wish the flow is diverse it's not even
close i just feel like a ghost cause
they sound like a version of me at my
worst gift and a curse i'm stuck with it
when this [ __ ] get too much to bear for
y'all well that's when i go in like the
covenant code and i'm running it flow
got a ton of them straight gunning them
down not one of them found no cap in my
rap no cap with the gown i'm in my own
lane you can't [ __ ] with my sound i just
let them be built just to break it all
down [ __ ] get cynical i can't stand the
praise i'm in love with the ridicule i
don't touch pen i ain't even touched
pinnacle i murder beats in two minute
intervals like wowzers drip might drown
her mic check one two turn me up louder
go harder than anyone out here until
[ __ ] click like internet browser lil
browse call me internet browser propane
through my whole name gotta search for
it they just wanna talk [ __ ] on the
internet won't admit it to themselves
that they just never wanna work for it
that's fine i'm barely trying only two
years and then i'm on the climb giving
two or more i'll sell out the troubadour
i'll probably pack it full of rappers
you adore them up the top with no
capping like two fedoras kill the verses
and forget to do the carvings talking
facts like a [ __ ] historian heard
your new [ __ ] it was whack it was boring
it's talk while i'm rapping you'll ruin
euphoria my [ __ ] is od like ruin
euphoria they cannot [ __ ] with the bull
like guitars record every day until my
voice get horror scoop on the
competition i've been navigating
he's so talented so how do you know him
we found him on a we did a white rabbit
white rapper
on this and then he won for weeks in a
row and he kept making he opened up for
me when i was in uh oh yeah i thought it
was san marcos
he's
so [ __ ] talented when is he coming
out with these songs that we did with
him it's it's coming the thing the thing
is i mean he's still working oh so this
is already out that song right there no
that's not that's on his instagram yep
he's such a savage yeah and he's yeah
and he works with and he works with this
producer man that's just space god he's
so so [ __ ] jealous
of savant yeah yeah you know
and such a good dude he works at a uh
addiction place like we have played
counselor thing because he used to be an
addict so now he like gives back and he
works at a yeah that place and then he
has a daughter he's just a beast dude
yeah
he's a motivating [ __ ]
he's so talented um
i like that guy wow
seventy percent of the men i know have
erectile dysfunction dude i'm guessing
try a hundred percent of the men i know
really it's a real problem
and there's four men in here we're
battling a hundred percent that's true
baby let me go won't shut up about it i
said bro you need to get roman bro yeah
well he got that al dente baby who
doesn't yeah who knows
when the moment for intimacy arrives
usually you stay in your car you'll take
a drive to the grocery store like i will
right or put on a sports game but
times have changed you got to be ready
and nobody's more ready than the romans
maybe you gotta get roman.com k-a-t-s
right now you can speak to health care
professional about your wiener all right
and get 15 buckaroos off your first
month of treatment
you don't have to be embarrassed of it
anymore man the whole process is
straightforward it's convenient it's
discreet it ships free to you in two
days yep two days who's going down daddy
in 48 hours you could be getting hard
with your friend man the whole process
is straightforward convenient and
discreet baby yeah man get started it's
simple just go to getroman.com
kats and complete an online visit you
don't have to go see a doctor visit a
man or woman and they're going to hit
that hit your penis with that little
hammer that's it yeah you don't want to
talk about the reflexes times have
changed that doesn't even work man a lot
of those people aren't even licensed
yeah it's complete an online visit today
to connect with a u.s licensed
healthcare professional and take care of
it go to getroman.com cats today you got
to do it if you're prescribed you get 15
bucks off your first month of ed
treatment make sure you're ready to have
confidence and control this fall roman
ready get that blaster a lot of forehead
here yeah
this is a lot of forehead oh dude this
shirt i mean dude you got it's
unbelievable your fans the shirt do you
like it or no no it's this isn't she's
going home
he's not
if i saw this guy out in anywhere i'd be
like oh that guy knows king of this
thing yeah shirt bro what is this how
about your show you'd like those are
your faces oh 100
just dudes but it's not even it's not
your fans necessary some of them not all
of them but some of them it's just like
all right
they're saying they're cavemen yeah yeah
just
dude they get out of [ __ ] the the
cars from mad max f350s
at the improv like where are you guys
from
far away
what the [ __ ] we came to la we've heard
of laughing we want to experience
we haven't left
and then would they go in the [ __ ]
improv and then you do jokes and they're
like
[Laughter]
just [ __ ] big not fat or muscly
muscly
you know what i mean [ __ ] yeah that was
for you bro and everyone laughed but you
you don't you know rocksteady and bebop
i'm with you
because you thought it was serious
i'm on the island remember
[Laughter]
king of this thing what's up this your
boy austin from tyler texas my boy
austin
january 1st got married nice
me and the wife we uh we met on tinder
about six months ago okay that's quick
that's texas first time i went to meet
her parents she said i couldn't tell
them that uh we met from tinder so we
had to come up with something else we
can't so old school everyone meets on
that [ __ ] meter on the candle all at
target and i asked her about some
flavors of the candles it works for my
debate club for you
should i tell them at one point
no down the road how we actually met no
well they definitely watch king of the
sting so they're going to find out
his game game buzz buzz
his dad's bebop yeah
i'll tell you though that's so funny
like it's such an old school thing like
to be like no no online tinder [ __ ] it's
like dude dude like we were indoors i
think for two years sixty percent sixty
percent of couples meet is some form of
social media but there was a time though
like 10 15 years ago oh yeah it was
weird it was like it was like a stigma
too it was weird yeah and now it's just
like no
to me it's crazy because now if you
think about it like why would you want
to talk to somebody at target so weird
walmart what is this [ __ ] 1940s
why are you looking at me
no i'm just sitting you're talking i'm
saying how do you even do it you meet
your girl via social media yeah yeah i
have mine in real life yeah i met mine
in real life
i met mine in real life too
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah mom was outside the
comedy store dude
yep did a show is that real life
fair enough
but this is not so dude you know and
hopefully this doesn't offend your wife
you know i was watching this documentary
on uh playboy last night on a e
your girl that looks like a better like
natural version of uh holly heard it
before i've heard that you've heard that
before yeah
um my girl's like yes his wife is so
much prettier i'm like yeah that's what
i'm saying yeah she's interested yeah
but no but i thought but when i was i
don't know how old she is now but when i
was like when i found out who she was
like
15 years ago or whatever yeah 20. yeah i
thought that she was so hot yeah that
holly is her name yeah yeah yeah yeah um
that documentary it's a ten part series
about eight parts too long about i mean
playboy series
[Laughter]
that's exactly what he did he goes like
that they're doing what to who
[Laughter]
especially because check it out man
cosby was it was a huge part of that he
was there all the time
hold up there was social media back then
oh you'd be surprised we would find out
what a player cosby was no jokes
cosby even even i think it was like
early 2000s got accused of rape in the
playboy
oh really even back then but what about
but like you hear all these things about
all these guys
like i don't want to say the guy's names
but like you hear these guys in the
[ __ ] like really famous people and
you're like is anything going to happen
and
it might or it might not and some guys
just [ __ ] make it out and they're
okay and some guys check out and then
some guys
get hit hard you know i mean like the
playboy matches things dicey right
because he built this entire empire like
selling sex yeah like these girls like
so it's like half and half half the
girl's like it was a cult it was
terrible i was forced to do this right
the other half like it's pretty dope we
lived in a mansion i knew i signed up
for it got really famous made a bunch of
money this is that this is on the
documentary it's like half and half yeah
it's what it was like 40 years ago that
they're talking about dude i mean you
know yeah they're like yeah it was me
paul newman arnold schwarzenegger was
19. it's like yeah but they got that but
but right now now we're looking back you
know how people look back at your
twitter and they go when you were 15 you
tweeted this well this is even worse
because they're going like hey you were
at the playboy mansion you know whatever
and now people are looking at that and
being like oh you're terrible
yeah
i mean that's the thing about 2022 it's
that's what i'm saying but
yeah and 70s and then we're talking
about quaaludes it's like that's
something that's what those dudes and
people did back then i know but you know
what i'm saying it's like now yeah but
that's the [ __ ] that's but that's a
slippery slope man cause you could even
go back and be like well in the 1700s
they're trying to you know but that's
what they're trying to do i know but
what i'm saying they're canceling they
try to cancel [ __ ] what's his name
john wayne remember yeah from uh from
being racist or something yeah yeah he's
dead he for sure was racist yeah but
he's dead well everyone was racist back
then yeah it was like you know i know
but but
if if they have a ledger like if you
have to sign in to go to the playboy
mansion they're bringing that up now
like you are a part of this is that fair
though look i don't i don't know i don't
think it's fair but at the same time
though you go look this is my feeling if
you if we're going to continue to use
sex to sell things
women and even men are going to be
objectified
okay that's just if you're going to use
sex to sell then that's what it's going
to be well if i if i drive down the
street and i see like you know and
sunset they always get a billboard of
like some bad [ __ ] on the uh on the
billboard selling like whatever it is
and i'm like who's that for
why she
make it oh i buy it every time i know
but that's what i'm saying so i'm like
you can't have that in society and then
also be like why are you objectifying
women correct okay then why are we like
it's like when i go to a restaurant
that's why i'm saying the companies
don't give a [ __ ] that's what i agree i
totally agree it's like when i go to a
restaurant man and like
mean this happens in vegas all the time
i was at a gordon ramsay restaurant in
vegas
the waitress's
outfits mm-hmm i'm talking about
it was so sexy and [ __ ] what are ace and
titties got to do with selling
hamburgers did you not enjoy it
that's no i was uncomfortable because i
was like oh man you know you felt like
you're at hooters yeah man and i'm like
listen if if i if you if you blindfold
yourself
when i bring you a hamburger you're not
gonna be like this tastes like a fat guy
brought it you know what i mean yeah
yeah i would but yeah yeah i'm just
saying it just it's like
eric
you know i understand why is there
butter so the moment we and why do they
do that it's like you know it's like we
do that stuff
it translates to money so but then it's
like at the same time it's like it also
translates to we're objectifying so the
boy mentioned i'm saying playboy and
hustler and all that it was all about
that remember they used to have that
club at the the palms
what is it remember that remember that
they had that comedy club at that time
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then they always have a playboy
model yeah yeah i remember that you know
i remember one of them she was telling
me that this is what happens the the
those the guys that own this they come
and they ask for the playboy model yeah
because you send her up to loose right
yeah can you send her up to like you
know and i was like damn that's so it's
like what's really going on here oh yeah
well just they can't do that now
you know or or they're like before they
can yeah and or they're doing it and
some girls like it and some don't yeah
yeah yeah but that's that's [ __ ] as
you say
the women that say like it they don't
want to come out and be like yeah i like
this because then all the other ones are
going to be like you're terrible don't
say that so it's like it's always
and here's another thing too you don't
change anybody with shame nobody makes
it worse shame
you can't shame somebody into changing
them to what you want to be it's just
going to push them over to the other i
make the joke about right chris
you know what i mean
but like dude it's real you can't shame
somebody into your channel make it worse
you can't you say do better do this [ __ ]
but then [ __ ] what's
do better it's it's like morgan uh
wallin right morgan whaley yeah so he
got caught calling his friend yeah he's
drunk yeah someone some neighbor
recorded it
they take him off all the country music
awards everything his the fans which pay
your bills his his album sale number one
yeah for months yeah once
the rapper i forget which rapper brought
him on stage a rapper because they're
like man people make mistakes he opens
up for this rapper and he has a hit i
forget who it is it's a huge [ __ ] now
okay a little bit a little dark i can't
believe you'd bring him in and the
rapper's like why right because because
that that recording when he was hammered
yeah that some random person took we're
supposed to
label him a racist right how long do you
want to do this well that's not like we
know like and he goes little dirt goes i
know him yeah we're friends
like so i'm putting him on my show yeah
and the people who don't know him are
like [ __ ] him this is [ __ ] and have
you heard the banger no broadway hoes or
something like that no but see the thing
is like the real point you made right
there is like how long are we supposed
to punish someone like at what point can
people redeem themselves at what point
can people be like i'm not i made this
mistake i'm not this person anymore and
it's like so how long do you want to
pile on someone especially with
celebrities because we do it with like
our judicial system when like prison
prison is supposed to be rehabilitation
they're supposed to get better and they
won't put all these resources into that
it's like okay well if you do this the
same with the celebrities whether you
can't for whatever
after two years and they're better three
years and they're a better person for it
and they learn their lesson like should
they not be able to make a like what's
good enough because it's not about they
don't want them to be better they don't
want to ruin their life no they want
they want yeah they want to ruin your
life and but why do they well a bunch of
different reasons because they're not a
bunch of different it's a bunch of
different reasons some people are mad at
their own life some people uh want the
power some people are mentally not right
some people i mean there's just so many
different reasons and some people really
think well [ __ ] we don't need those
[ __ ] in society and uh and and
they need society needs to be better
whatever you think dude whatever you
think it's like you know being being
like these guys like morgan whalen could
have [ __ ] been like i'm still going
to go out and do shows i don't give a
[ __ ] the next day that that's basically
what he's doing well he he kind of took
he took some time off a little bit but
but but you know that's to for him it
was probably dude bro these
[ __ ] shame you it makes you
want to [ __ ] kill yourself bro i mean
i'm not [ __ ] around anybody like it's
not helping anybody it makes it worse
like it makes you i mean people are out
there bro i watched uh love island man i
love that show
three people killed themselves from that
show you know because in britain people
britain i know because the [ __ ]
president well it's a step it's a step
ahead of the american press the american
press is [ __ ] awful too they [ __ ]
make these people these are real people
that are like all right [ __ ] it if
you're gonna say this for [ __ ]
however long i'm not that girl was her
name's heidi or something she committed
suicide yeah she had so much pressure
and she's just three people three people
from that show she was the host yeah the
host and
gorgeous like not a [ __ ] 10. it's and
then she was going through issues with
her boyfriend and like [ __ ] hit the news
she just killed herself
i mean these people are real people man
they don't think that they're real
people because they just see them on tv
and they're just like oh it's so easy to
just be like [ __ ] this person out all
you hater
cats fans uh-huh that's exactly what i'm
talking about yeah it's the truth man
it's a shame dude i don't know how it
changes well that's how people that's
how people that's what they want
you know and i feel your passion about
this and i understand why you even feel
this way too and it's just this is what
i'm saying too it's like it to to that
point
you know
whatever happens how do you move forward
from it and people need to acknowledge
the moving forward
it's terrible man it also doesn't just
affect you man it affects i mean you
know yeah yeah
no i know people get older and [ __ ]
people get affected and it's just it's i
mean bro it's it's not even about the
person it's about their family it's
about their [ __ ] i mean dude
everything
i wish [ __ ] out there knew but
i don't know maybe one day they will and
no they they never will because they
don't take any risks they don't do
anything of note and you know what they
think that's why they want to bring
others down but the thing that they just
really messed up about it too is like so
this guy this rapper who's like this is
my friend so this is the thing that i
don't understand too it's like so it's
like
i'm not supposed to support my friend
correct you know what i mean so it's
like uh i can't
here's my friend who i'm trying to
like
you know be like i'm supposed to just
shun my friend and be like i don't want
to be around my friend anymore because
you guys don't like it
dave chappelle but but it's even bigger
than that chris my thing is like so
social media goes after this guy right
and that guy's one of my close friends
so it's like so from the information
that you have you think you know more
than i do i know the i know what's going
on i have the truth here and you think
if i thought that that really happened i
would [ __ ] with that person
yeah yeah yeah yeah check my track
record
i don't [ __ ] people like that
so who are you going to ride with these
random trolls or someone i've known for
years and even what are you going to do
and go
do the background but go even further
than that man you go even if it's like
press
as if like so that doesn't count no no
no no no no no this is what i'm saying
no that's what i'm saying this exactly
so i'm saying like so i'm saying that if
you have somebody somebody writes an
article right so if you're someone that
goes well i believe i believe this
then i don't want to ever hear you
complain about fox news i agree i don't
want to hear you complaining about cnn i
don't want to hear you complaining about
tmz because it's the price page six so
everything that they write must be true
right so i don't want to go here
you know what i mean so so that's what
i'm saying so if you go well here's an
article this person must be have no
agenda or anything that's why they did
this it's like oh no no everything has a
spin yeah you know everything has a spin
you must believe all politicians yeah
to tell you this
ribs away from you i will tell you
though you do love her i love ribs i
love ribs
my face i will tell you though that
shirt is a i like that i like that shirt
the shirts fire the back's camo though
is it double rl is it
man that would be funny
uh last debate club
what up king of sting it's your boy jake
here back with another debate club uh so
over the weekend the bills played the
chiefs and during the game a fan decided
to storm the field
turns out his boys paid him a thousand
dollars to do so so my question for you
guys is how much money would it take you
to storm the fields of a playoff game
now eric i know fences probably aren't
your thing
dalia you kind of got the physique of uh
salad fingers so
people would pay top dollar see you get
bodied
uh and shop
this could be your opportunity man get
in there start squeezing some ass grab
some cheeks like the good old days you
know what i'm saying that capitalize on
your opportunities
so i'd love to hear what you guys got to
say gang gang buzz buzz i like that guy
i like that guy that's the best guy that
ever called in yeah
wait so um this guy's storming the field
for a thousand dollars you get dealt
security is foaming at the dick to
tackle you
they live for this moment nothing ever
happens
too what stefan did yeah that's what i'm
saying he got lit up see him running yep
watch stefan diggs boom
ooh
that's cool he got tackled yeah you know
why stefan diggs is top five receivers
this would be like this would be like
you're doing your
netflix hour yeah you're doing your
special this is like a big deal and then
some [ __ ] runs on the stage
oh it's horrible what he did is [ __ ]
these kids are in playoff games
dude oh dude oh i hope you heard it
top five games i've ever seen oh i know
yeah i wish my bills won but top five
games
that's just
but also does anybody know the guy's
name that rushed the field you get no
fame i know yeah well you got a thousand
dollars
you get what i'm paying for your friends
because he gets arrested you gotta go to
jail you gotta post bail right here's
your thousand dollars yeah yeah but he's
still nothing he got the story yeah but
this guy's for sure this guy's getting
pushy off this there's no doubt i
disagree i don't think so you've seen
some girls like hold up you're the guy
that rushed the field yeah i do yeah i
don't think so oh you're discounting
those kind of clothes
oh
dude
that's my argument always people like
not for that oh but
oh
that's true
people have different feelings yeah this
is a swole dude so we got a cats in the
wild uh evidently chappelle
and me right
chabelle was pissed that he heard chris
picked uh brendan okay
i've seen this jesus christ
hold on a second what
like what that is that guy drunk yeah
yeah yeah
oh
he's also a hammer because he was like
hey bro it's all good yeah yeah yeah so
actually because he didn't hit him he
was it look he's like
he probably shouldn't have hit him that
hard but also yeah you can't fault him
for hitting him yeah right right right
he also benches 700 pounds yeah like
that's
i actually saw that i've never seen this
god that looks like a green room that
you would [ __ ] play in like
in like cleveland at a casino or some
[ __ ] you know what i mean i'm sure
you've covered some other shows but how
are the hamstrings do it that didn't
that get better
did you stretch you stretched not at all
oh this one
you were at the combine yeah
i [ __ ] up i do i worked me and
chappelle worked out legs that morning
and ran two miles
we went and ate chilled out and then
brian was like you guys race today right
i'm like you want to do it she was like
[ __ ] you let's do it right and then
right when we're about to like i like
people didn't see this we start and i
take off and she broke no you started
early didn't start early but i my right
hand went boink i went oh [ __ ] dude my
my hammies are tight chapelle goes bro
we don't need to do this man this we
don't [ __ ] up tough mudder he's like who
cares who's faster i'm like now let's
just do it the camera's here [ __ ] it
let's do it and then boom dude we're
going i can feel it go
just [ __ ] so okay so you started the
race i'm i'm basically jose canseco i
got peptides hgh i got [ __ ] muscle
relaxers you got a lot in you
anti-inflammatories i hook up to a
system every night i gotta make this
tough mudder baby
no carbs in three weeks that's bad so
you started so you started the race and
then started it again yes oh after i get
hurt okay
so right there i it's not doing and then
there that's where it is oh dude bad
chip out with his shirt off
not good you want to get hit again it
does but i mean just being you know if i
was a fan watching and i don't know all
this stuff yeah it kind of looks like
he was about to win all right then all
because also that angle would favor
chappelle anyway and i'm still ahead so
yeah no yeah yeah bro he was going to
work eric wish bro i'm thinking every
night of course
sports masseuse come to the house
hook my
he does halloween where like they they
have like everything the whole you know
it's like the scooby doo
famous person he's like there that's who
i am
i'll sit over here this is my outfit i
know we were like go ahead okay
is that justin
i'm oj
yeah i'm sarah mclaughlin go do [ __ ]
uh we got some kingdoms
hey i i'm joking around about this a lot
but it's actually true
this this is the same guy
he's just outside get
what's up with like
getting a guy with like who's not why
don't you like the bro
guy
who is the winner doesn't have facial
hair and no hat
and no and like what the [ __ ] is going
on dude
or a chick like what's happening
hey man yeah with all these guys welcome
to cats guys with beards [ __ ] tickets
[ __ ] on congratulations [ __ ]
would be like hi we're doing the thing
and chicks will be like hey bro what are
who the [ __ ] are these [ __ ]
it's just guys bro there's bros
this is austin no
no
louisiana i'm a plant operator out here
working a 7-7 schedule uh that's a total
king of this thing for you guys
being away from home to work
the worst i know a lot of you guys on
the road doing things like that i'm not
being awake and being good and a bad
thing just wanted to get you guys
opinion
i'm good when it's like
and i have it dialed in now where i'll
do a week in the beginning of the month
week and end of the month and i'll do
sets around town in between that but
when you do like three weekends in a row
which i used to do bro
thursday through not for depending on
what you have at home if that's what it
is dude when you have kids well i don't
that's when they're little guy i don't
get like guys like
i don't understand like bro now that i
have calvin and like a family at home i
i haven't been away from calvin for one
night
uh since he's been born oh it's
heartbreaking and wait till they're old
enough to realize you're like my son
will be in tears right on my leg when
i'm like am i i don't know man but guys
who do the road like there are comics
that have families that are on the road
every weekend insane
but also if that's how you have to pay
the bills like but it's not though some
of these guys it's not they're not
somebody just want to escape you know
what i'm saying but every time i get i
know i don't get it i don't understand
why you laugh at that weirdo just look
at that video coming up next edition but
yeah so it's so like it that's like you
haven't started touring wait till you do
it it's difficult i know and i'm going
to and i'm going to bring them sometimes
but you can't bring them all the time so
like
um it's [ __ ] hard man i don't know
how often are you on the road eric i go
like it'll be like two weeks yeah two
three weeks out of the month yeah three
is a lot two is doable two is doable
even like i don't got a kid yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but even still it's
like i i you know rachel's all no no
it's two yes it's even just like are you
going again you know what i mean
that's what i'm saying i know that's i
mean even if that's something it becomes
harder that's where the pandemic showed
me i'm like oh i work too much me too
shut down yeah
i'm on the road waiting
what do you need all that [ __ ] money
for like for what dude you have it all
you already have it all yeah you got to
slow down dude it's not my [ __ ] was all
about oh just keep going don't stop oh
they want me to go where okay [ __ ] it
i'll go if that's what they want bro i
was gone so much what are you doing it
for agree
agree for what and that that's one of
the bright sides we're all of this
pandemic we're all equally as happy yeah
you know i mean you can't you're not
buying happiness no you're happier when
you're at home you're happier like in
your schedule you're more comfortable
you've got two or three bathtubs now yep
but it's kind of like yeah yeah you
gotta say
remember
no i stay back
though yeah i'm all about yeah i know
[ __ ] i said it for you
also um
all right
let's see another guy that looks the
same
holy [ __ ] he does look the same
i mean you know what i mean
patagonia carhartt hold on a second
we're supposed to be boycotting carhartt
that's yeah
[ __ ]
up cause it's hip no carhart they added
vaccine mandates for their employees oh
but that's everybody's doing that
they're not though well nike did it
you're [ __ ] what do you got on
what you got
you gonna make a stand now
i would
anyway
that's a [ __ ] tone
i will tell you this right now when it
comes to a company doing something or
this guy said that or this person
supported trump [ __ ] that whatever the
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] dude no if i
like this shoe i buy the goddamn shoes
dude when people i walk around the easy
way connie was supporting trump people
like you're gonna wear that [ __ ] you
dude the shoe's nice no now have i
warmed my traffic i don't give a ton
since that happened if i tell you what i
have i've worn travis scott's shoes
because you know why they're my favorite
wanted to i know me too [ __ ] all that
[ __ ]
i don't know what happened yeah yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] if you're not
wearing travis scott because of the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] i agree oh bro they lit me up
i talked about this on my podcast and
they [ __ ]
i can't bro it's hit how the [ __ ] is it
his fault agree any performer knows you
know what i'm saying
you can't see [ __ ] i do a percentage of
what the [ __ ] crowd is i'm close you
can't even 50 000 people you can't see
[ __ ] you can't see [ __ ] with 400 people
if you do a theater you can't well they
don't want to they don't want to get
into the details of the logistics of the
whole thing they don't want to sit here
and be like okay well there was security
that they did this and who who who let
you slip and who let that it just
becomes all bogged down so they just go
who's the name let's blame him and then
it feels better to do that yeah of
course because he's at the top he's at
the top but he's like people like he saw
an ambulance and got and here i am i'm
like well if you're up there and you see
an ambulance going to do the thing then
oh you're you're up there you're like oh
good they're doing their job
do you know what i'm saying yeah oh
someone's dehydrated yeah who knows what
the [ __ ] you but imagine if they would
have done this though if they would have
said let's shut it all down like before
like people are nuts
it'd be even more of an uproar
what do you got nick just a couple more
here what's up guys terry moon out here
in the beautiful bloomsdale missouri wow
just had a quick king here you move guys
demolition derbies you know i've heard
you guys talk about it a couple times
never really gotten a full conversation
on it have we talked about it's been a
huge pass because i was a kid absolutely
love it
all right let me know what you guys
think did you win some awards smash man
yeah you got awards right there dude
i'll tell you right now if you're gonna
if you're gonna be passionate about
something you do that [ __ ] and if you're
gonna be doing demolition derma you
better be the [ __ ] best for real
that's cool that's cool is there
somebody who's the best though why do
they just like break their cars
they just run into each other right wow
this is still a thing i didn't know it
was a thing i do i didn't know monster
trick was a thing to add kids i went to
monster truck this past saturday bro
you're talking about angel stadium sold
the [ __ ] out and backed why it was the
one of these people you've ever seen
yeah all day so there was a lot of the
improv
there's a lot of this going on hey man
yeah
there was a lot of game
games and you know where i'm at you guys
look at my girl yeah there's a lot of go
brand insurance here yeah yeah there's
so many
wait isn't it [ __ ] you brandon no it's
go brandon let's go brandon let's go
let's go brandon right right right right
right that's cool
all right all right give me one more
nick i you roll all right
are you okay
dude you did this on purpose you did
this i picked this one specifically are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me dude great baby
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me i mean it's
the cutest one though look at these eyes
what's going on with heart problems
i'll take some questions here i got a
king or sting it for you guys that wear
uh jeans with flip-flops personally
never do it my friend where is it 365 a
year is your friend brian
i saw this guy he was hilarious roasting
him a little bit that's all i wanted um
you can catch the full clip at
chrissychaos.com patreon and uh boys i'm
looking to be part of a tenders list
with those eyes
make it work daddy uh all right i don't
know his friend i mean
listen for your friend the santa's the
least of it
you feel me i have no problem with this
hey i'll tell you right now
hold up in what world did we get so
[ __ ] comfortable where you think
sandals is appropriate attire for the
airport a comedy show dinner you're
[ __ ] you're open toe no [ __ ] out of
your mind
you know what the one time i i had
something like that on and i went to
like the bathroom in a urinal all pissed
off and i realized
how
i think australia like maybe new york a
long flight and i was barefoot i took my
feet swell on the plane so i was
barefoot walking and i go in there and
the stewardess when i come out she goes
honey you know that's not water on the
ground right and why she goes it's never
water on the ground
you don't put on the first class socks
no no
are you a fan of yours
this is something that a troglodyte
would do yeah uh clion this is yours
your hepatitis feet now now i will say
this i've had all three variants of
covid original code omnicron and
whatever the [ __ ] he's got hep feet
exactly
it's a title episode dude listen okay
you pepe hold on you simplex 10. this is
uh this is i i don't have a problem with
any sh like if you're going to go to a
cafe and it's summer and you want to
wear that no you can't no you can't why
sandals for the beach okay so you think
santa's for the beach period the only
bee okay okay if you're at a resort and
you're on a beach and you walk into a
cafe and you get breakfast yeah you got
your sandwich you got a resort though
okay yeah that is what i'm saying yeah
that's fine fair enough okay if you go
to like groundworks off mainstream no no
no no no no no no no no no no yeah yeah
don't do that put jeans on
i think well okay but slides or anything
with socks is okay right like slides
with socks
out with jeans are you on 60 days in but
that's why why are you dressed like that
why do you have socks with sandals love
60 days in yeah me too love it well i
don't i like the gigs up on it
i don't
yeah that shit's done they're like i
think they're on to us see and they got
a code word like to go up the camera
like grab their neck if they need to get
out of there yeah they're like this guy
i would never why the [ __ ] would you
want to go into prison how about homeboy
who did so it's 60 days in after 60 he
was running [ __ ] he's like i'm actually
pretty comfortable i'm doing another 60.
he does 120 days so he's on season one
and two oh that's the dude that was like
yeah then he did a third season wow he's
just injured
he basically murdered somebody
he's in for 180 days
gets out commit suicide
oh yeah because are you [ __ ] me i
bet you somebody
i don't even worry
that's what i'm saying dude yeah but
those are the guys that wear sandals
with socks as much okay
okay i think chris is he's he's kind of
like skating around right now that he's
got like some slippers at home so i'm
like yeah he sucks
i'm trying to he wears out i'm trying to
think if i've worn i don't think i've
ever i don't know if i've worn slippers
and socks i don't know
but what about like yeezys and [ __ ] he
goes to get coffee
i don't give a [ __ ] with a gucci ton you
can't you can't wear open toes out in
public okay so he's saying with socks
i'm saying with socks
so so just you wear slides though no i
don't oh you don't no okay you don't
never
never interesting
i don't know how i feel about you you've
never seen me in sweats or slides
outside the house for the rare
instance i don't know how i feel about
this all right i always have a take i
don't have one i don't know i don't know
you you know what dude guy with the eyes
you got me
and i and i'm pissed
i'm pissed
pep feet
is that it nick that's it all right kids
i'm in atlanta next week thursday friday
saturday atlanta punchline come get some
atl and then end of end of uh
february i am in sacramento get your
tickets at f-a-t-k-z.com or thickboy.com
fight companions available now with
crystallia myself and brian cowan uh
make sure you like subscribe to thick
boy to watch all that stuff we got a
special food truck dropping today eric
what do you got doug i mean i think it's
bloomington missouri is that a is that a
place
yeah is that near ozarks you may you
made it up no but yeah i'm going to be
in missouri missouri's dope i love them
yeah so check that out what venue um i
forgot the name of the place
um i have dates uh in brea california
winning february 18th
and 19th oh nice crystally in france oh
i think i'm around oh really i'm a
friend you guys are on if you want i'm
off the middle of february i'll be so
funny let me see february 18th yeah i'm
there oh [ __ ] yeah dude there i'm going
to do the last ones all right i'm with
san diego i'm in san diego with you on
saturday after that breakfast oh if you
want to run the tough mudder saturday 10
a.m the thick mudder we have seven spots
left to run with my
blown out hammies thick mudder 10 and
then i got a
irvine i'm going to do in april but
anyway i don't know if my the dates are
up so far away though you know i know
what you're asking me this is what i got
bro okay he's the only dude he's all
chicago 2027. make sure you come out and
get tickets but that's what
i said new
know what new year's
20-28 you know what bro and when it
sells out everyone gets [ __ ] mad
but it's what happens everyone's like i
chose in san diego i'm not [ __ ]
watching everybody
yet but you better [ __ ] wait with
baited breaths
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at paw
way
now he only finished boys in the hallway
this ain't the greatest show on earth
and what you call that eric griffin with
them he the nate dogger podcast
[Music]
griffin just walked in and got it lit
you can't forget about brendan he still
need everything dick dick still got the
bees and the trap trapping
still the king in the sting so quit
asking if you know then you know it's a
cat's thing ball and chain hair swang
like the rat king king and the stink
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan theo too yeah you
know how we do it so just tune in for
the laughs theo said that he was on his
way but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting
you